because everyone had such a positive
reaction to the first couch tomato
episode seriously you guys loved it we
decided we'd launch one per month right
here on the main channel for all of you
to enjoy counter tomato will still be
releasing a new one every week on his
own channel so if you guys want more go
subscribe to him there we starts off in
the far reaches of space
I'll pick like with the cliche deep
voice character explaining the backstory
of an army of Darkness and an upcoming
battle against mighty heroes right after
that is when we find out about this
MacGuffin device Tom out for clarity a
MacGuffin device is a plot device that
has no specific meaning or purpose other
than to advance the story I got the
definition from a pretty reliable source
and thought I share it since I
personally found out about the meaning
only a couple of weeks ago at least once
in the film the characters associate the
term Tess Iraq with the MacGuffin device
that I'm talking about Timon all right
you and I both know nobody wants to see
a movie set entirely in space unless it
rhymes with Star Wars or guardians of
the galaxy so the director finds a way
to get our main characters transported
to the 3rd for this planet from the Sun
to make it more relatable I guess at the
end of the day I'm not going to force
you to watch this movie I could admit
the plot is a little thin with the whole
basic good versus evil type stuff but
these characters are pretty awesome one
guy with the eye patch
I would totally wear that for Halloween
there's this inventor guy who serves as
the brains of the operation plus you got
this cutie and she's all like truth or
dare I don't care
underwears not under there last but not
least death mother know you weareth her
drapes the hero from another realm
that's allergic to obesity is starring
in the blockbuster also it's this main
character that shares the most history
with our bad guy more so than the other
good guys he's supposed to be this
worthy dude with this weapon where only
he could harness the full potential when
he uses it Lightning starts appear in
his stuff so he's kind of legit that's
for the bad guy in this movie the
British accent villain seems like an
underdog at first but you the viewer
might end up liking him more than the
heroes in this film other than the fact
that he's always begging people to know
before him he's pretty cool dude's got
some of the funniest lines in this movie
and he's got this staff thingy that can
transform it's close to a Michael
Jackson do you remember the time outfit
on command which is more comical than
frightening if anything hero movies
usually go the cheap route with the
heroes being all buddy-buddy and eating
swarmer like a big happy family
kudos to the director for getting some
tension in there after some finger
pointing in the woods the good guys
decide to put their differences aside
and partner to find out exactly what the
mysterious Macduff
devices capable of the villain gets
nervous not really sure why though he's
got way more people than the good guys
do in fact there's this one part where
he's all like I have an army and the
good guys like we have a character
that's already signed a contract for an
alleged future sequel so it's highly
unlikely the good guys die in this movie
to get leverage the bad guy hypnotize is
this one good guy character and starts
getting valuable secrets and stuff we
don't know something haha funny the plan
actually works yeah guys are able to
read the good guys place of operation
and get what they wanted while the
helpful heroes need help of their own
this government badge dude tries to jump
in the fight now it's obvious people
without power should stay on the
sidelines but he gets a gun and thinks
he's bulletproof and sadly he's not
anyways so this whole movie the bad guys
been bragging about this army but what I
act don't know that they are with the
help of the MacGuffin thinking there I
would have used the wormhole to
transport to the streets of the city
luckily in this film no innocent
civilians are seen dying on screen so
you could argue there's actually zero
casualties if you don't include the bad
guys plus some of the cops are able to
provide a hand
I'll admit cops usually suck in disaster
movies like this but they're able to
secure the perimeter and stuff while the
stronger heroes are occupied okay
speaking of Fresh Prince of bel-air this
one guy starts Will Smith ended up out
of nowhere
so aliens are flying all over the place
right and the heroes are like I've seen
these things in action and I'm well
aware of their maneuvering capabilities
this son of a be where it ends up
actually flying the space tricycle
thingy with no manual or nothing the
hero flies to the rooftop they get
closer to the MacGuffin but it sucks
because the force field surrounding the
MacGuffin device is impenetrable to make
matters worse and the good versus evil
battle the bad guys overwhelm the good
guys and it becomes too much for them to
handle you think for a split second the
good guys might lose this one who they
eventually separate the main villain
from his staff and win the battle in the
end the heroes huddle up and a blue
thingy majiggy to two of the main
characters right before they transport
back to their home planet this is
actually a fairy tale type ending but
not really since the after credits
scenes suggest that there's more sequels
and danger of course on the horizon
those are 24 reasons these movies are
the same you agree Yes No maybe so if
not politely share your thoughts in the
comment section below and click the
subscribe button for more 24 reason
videos